Are you ready to give it a try?
What are the set of media queries,
you need to apply in order to
apply styles from these classes?
Use this diagram as a guide.
Class AA applies from 0 to 400 pixels.
Class BB applies from 301 pixels to 600.
CC applies for any browser with a width,
greater than 601 pixels.
And DD applies for any browser with
a width greater than 961 pixels.
You'll need to write four media queries.
One for class AA, one for
class BB, CC, and DD.
In order for a class to display,
set it to display block.
And when you type out your answers.
Don't worry about new lines, just make
your media queries one long line so
they fit in the box.
I'll go ahead and start you off with
@media for each of the media queries.
And then at the end of it I went
ahead and drew these curly braces.
If these were real media queries,
this is where the styles would go.
Finish them up and good luck.